listen congrats on the movie i really
enjoyed it i like i like murder mystery
whodunit type movies
brilliant that's good that's a good
start
exactly so i definitely want to know um
you've obviously worked with tom before
um
you know and so was he any different
making the movie did he feel like he you
know what i mean working um on like a
bigger canvas or was he the same guy
from this country do you know what he i
was expecting him to be a bit more sort
of
yeah like arrogant and egotistical but
actually he was the same humble self
which was really nice but no because
we've yeah we've done free series
together and
loved the way he works and he just yeah
it was the same um the way he worked
with the actors was exactly the same
despite it being such a much bigger
production being a you know hollywood
film um what do you think soon-to-be
fans of the film would be like surprised
to learn about the making of the film
i mean we shot it during the pandemic
which was
sort of really really strange i mean um
but it meant that we were able to film
in a lot of these
famous theaters and places that we would
never had the opportunity before so
places like um the old vic and the
dominion theater which is like you know
the
key places in the in london's west end
and
savoy hotel
so because they were all shut down
during three months we were you know
able to film this it was making the best
out of a bad situation in other ways it
would have just been all in sort of
studios and on sets and
um so that was really really nice yeah
when i was watching the film i couldn't
believe some of the locations you guys
were using and then i read about uh you
know during covet and i'm like you got
so much production value out of um you
know
because of govind
completely yeah which is really really
great
um and it's you know these are real sort
of historical
places you just wouldn't have been able
to get access to before you got to work
with this great cast and i know it's a
little generic but like talk a little
bit about uh working with some of these
people because the whole film is just
littered with like a murderer's row of
talent
well exactly and you know what the fact
is a murder mystery and you've got two
detectives going on this journey trying
to interview various people and find out
who it is is is perfect for a great
ensemble because these you know the next
person that crops up is brilliant and
someone you know from
you know your favorite films and then
the other person is somewhat you know so
it's it was a really eclectic mix as
well and you've got real sort of
straightforward film actors people like
sasha but in a comedy which is so nice
because
her
comedic timing is so good and i don't
think i've ever seen her in anything
like this so
um so having a murder mystery was a
perfect vehicle for that which is really
nice and yeah everyone was
incredible as you expect and to be able
to have a scene with adrian brodie and
sam rockwell you know people that i look
up to so much and seeing them do their
thing in the flesh was just like it was
like a master class
um and he was like trying being so
conscious to try and live in the moment
but you're just sort of star struck at
the same time so it was like yeah
amazing you've obviously done your own
stuff for a number of years but what is
it like when you have a big scene with
like hollywood stars like the night
before are you like you know a little
bit more in your head the night before
when you're trying to go to bed are you
thinking about the scene more than you
thought you would
completely yeah totally but because
that's just the way
you know we put these film stars on
pedestals now and they are like our sort
of modern
version of gods aren't they they're just
sort of you can't help but feel anxious
before you do something like that with
them
um but you know having met them you just
realize they're sort of nice humble guy
so that was really really nice everyone
works a little bit of a different way
you know some people like music before a
take and some people like quiet i know
sam can be a little um i've spoken to
sam a number of times i know he likes to
work a certain way can you sort of talk
about uh the way you like to work on set
and how it compared or contrasted to
some of your cast mates
yeah i mean i i sort of
i really like having that time to get
into a character
and definitely listen to a lot of music
before doing the scenes and
i mean especially it was helpful for
this being the sort of 1950s period i
mean it's sort of um because once you
get the costume on and you can really
get lost in that world which is lovely
um but again
watching how other actors do it and get
into characters is really interesting
you know people adrian brodie can just
sort of switch on straight away i mean
that's why he's such an incredible actor
um and then sam rockwell who's someone
who sort of was in character sort of the
whole time even between scenes and
listens to a lot of music and i think
even one time he bought his lasso he was
really good at la suing
has he ever talked to you about that
before
he has not well i don't know it was some
sort of well-kept secret but he's like
indiana jones he's sort of like was
you know during breaks he was just suing
chairs it was a real
surreal thing but uh brilliant to watch
i'm going to be honest and say i haven't
seen this country before but for people
for for people that have not seen it how
do you how do you like to talk about it
to like to people like you know to sort
of mention to them the series
yeah i mean it's sort of it's about it's
a mockumentary and it just follows two
cousins who are sort of um
they're sort of like a bit like sort of
tear-aways they're a bit um you know
they don't work and they live in this
tiny village in a rural place in england
and it's just following their day-to-day
lives and about you know
sort of the boredoms that come with
living in a rural area and you know but
it touches upon some rural poverty and
stuff like that um
and they get themselves into you know
they're constantly trying to find their
own entertainment
um
and so it sort of sounds fairly basic
but it
gave us a lot of opportunity to
you know it's various different
characters um that come and go in that
world interesting characters and
actually there's the american version
that's out at the moment called welcome
to flatch because i think they're doing
a second series at the moment so
it's a sort of an idea that can
translate well sort of all over the
world really because you've got those
sort of characters wherever you know if
you grew up in a place that's um rural
there's not a lot of opportunities and
you can't work then what else you're
gonna do you're gonna get into trouble
which is sort of perfect for comedy i
suppose
i'm so curious about what you learned
because obviously you made more than one
season what did you learn making the
first season that you took with you when
you made additional episodes i mean it's
interesting i mean i think the fact that
with stuff like twitter and social media
you can get that instant feedback can't
you if you type in the hashtag this
country i can see what anyone has ever
written about the show so i think we did
that doofy um did that a few times after
the first series it was quite
interesting what people picked up on and
and i think we learned a lot about
what um
what people wanted to find out about the
characters which was really nice and um
their back stories and i think later on
in the series we're like oh perhaps we
should you know it was literally people
asking
um oh does so you know does the vicar
have a wife or does the vicar have
children and it's like actually i
haven't thought about that so
we sort of used that in later series and
you know gave us great storylines which
was really nice what are you working on
now are you writing anything
yeah right yeah there's a couple of
projects all really early days like
there's not really much to say but no i
do love the writing aspect of it and i
think definitely being in this film
inspired me to do something that was
more
thrilling more dramatic but combining
those sort of comedy moments i think is
such a great combination on that note
i'm just going to say congrats and um i
hope this launches you know more uh work
for you which is
the most important thing amazing lovely
to meet you thank you so much cool have
a fantastic afternoon thank you
you